aujourd'hui mondialement or c'est une
famille cette famille ils ont un
problème c'est que les enfants qui
grandissent et leurs problèmes ses trois
frères et quand ils ont contredit ses 15
ans et là les parents le pépin c'est que
maintenant ils sont obligés de trouver
des défuntes pour aller faire l'amour
quoi et donc ils montrent un plan ils
disent 'voilà ce soir quand qu'on va
manger voilà quand je vais servir la
soupe chérie je vais faire exprès ton
renversé sur la chemise comme ça toi tu
vas partiront pour aller de changer et
moi comme je sais où sont tes chemise je
vais te rejoindre
ils montrent leur plomb c'est parti le
soir arrive le repas la mer et sert la
soupe au premier et au deuxième au
troisième enfant et arrive au père push
et à lui pourrir sa chemise
le père a fait semblant de viol et voilà
ma chemise maire de regarde au point de
faire bas la junte après tu encore
d'accord qu'on a des gars les acteurs
donnent évidemment oui c'est donc tu
manques se changer la mère dit aux
enfants à la lame et votre père il sait
pas où sont les chemises je vais le
rejoindre je vais l'aider
et donc là les deux arrivent dans la
chambre en sa part sept chars nadal il
enlève tout la mer sur le lavabo le père
bam bam
mais entre temps il ya un petit qui
monte et voit la scène donc il
redescendra ses frères idiots les
frérots renversé par votre soupe parce
que papa il va vous faire un truc de fou
aller très bien oui bon ça se passe dans
une classe la maîtresse elle vit classe
de ce2 demain voilà pour le l'exposé sur
la médecine il travaillait sur les
métiers de demain
ramé chacun amène un truc de chez lui
qui soigne les gens
ok donc le lendemain à la petite emilie
a ramené du doliprane hadj assez bien
dire oui le doliprane
ça sert à soigner les gens qui ont mal à
la tête adia ça c'est très bien elle est
tout à kayes médical moi j'ai ramené du
mercurochrome n'y a pas si c'est bien ça
soigne les gens qui se blesse et
beltoise sébastien dia moi j'ai ramené
tout en bouteille d'oxygène de mamie a
dit c'est bien eh oui ta mamie elle t'a
laissé didier par les pompiers
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]